I get those goosebumps every time I need
time throw that to this aisle
I can't do songs every what is up guys
today I will be showing you how to make
loads of money super fast so as you can
see I sold the cannon sets for seven
hundred eighty nine thousand so in order
to do this all you have to do is
teleport to the monastery using a combat
bracelet
run down here
West
one down here
open the store and talk to the door and
originally in my other methods where I
showed this I thought you had to drop
the cannon because I thought he wouldn't
tell you one if you had one in your
inventory
but that's not true so you can actually
do it much quicker as you can see I have
a timer in the top right corner so
basically you're going to want to keep
holding the spacebar then click one then
click one again and then hold the
spacebar again and then click one again
hold the spacebar
and then he will show you the cannon
just keep it in inventory and continue
doing this buying it for 750 K because
right now the cans are selling for 789 K
so that's a 49 K profit per cannon and
let's see how long it takes to do all
this
[Music]
so that took a minute in 40 seconds to
buy them all so now teleport to the
grand exchange turn your dwarf cannons
pieces into sets go ahead and put them
in for an offer I'm going to put them in
for 789 K and then I'm going to buy a
new combat bracelet and redo the process
again
[Music]
[Applause]
so some from the last run already sold
so I'm going to go ahead and take this
money and go back and do it again while
these other ones are selling
[Music]
you
[Applause]
so I'm going to go ahead and do this
again I'm going to teleport back and
then buy some more caiman sets while
these ones are trying to sell
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going to go ahead and let all these
sit for someone g9k and if I change the
prices I'll go ahead and show you guys
it's been about two minutes and nothing
selling after a while so I'm going to go
ahead and collect them all and put in a
new offer for 780 K and we'll go ahead
and see how long it takes for these to
sell it's been almost nine minutes and
not all of them have sold yet so I'm
going to go ahead and put them in for
770 K to try to get them done quickly if
they have all sold in just above 20
minutes so now I'm going to do some math
and see how much money I made I bought
and sold all the cannon pieces in about
20 minutes so 750 K times the 15 cannon
sets
okay so I'll write that down there
eleven million two hundred fifty
thousand so we don't forget that number
and now I will add up all the prices of
what we sold them for 789 K and the
final group two million three hundred
sixty-seven K all right so 11 million
six hundred sixty-six minus eleven
million two hundred fifty thousand
416 K so I made 416 K in 20 minutes so
60 divided by 3 is 20 so if you did this
for an hour to be in 1 point 2 4 8
million but I made 416,000 in 20 minutes
that is just insane I hope you guys like
this video and I hope you love my new
intro let me know in the comments and
thanks for watching guys stay tuned for
the next video
you
Oh